à tous les
joueurs il est l'heure de passer au jeu
suivant j'hallucine incroyable veuillez
entrer dans la salle de jeux sans
tarder c'est quoi ça
séeux c'est pas
vrai que le jeu
commence
[Musique]
ce jeu est vraiment
cruel merde
alors pour espérer l'emporter il faut
avoir une bonne stratégie je serai ton
meilleur pote mais j'hésiterai pas à
trahir on peut faire confiance à
personne vous devez désigner deux
joueurs à
[Musique]
éliminer mec c'est squid gametoi plutôt
de
l'écouler on forme une bonne équipe tu
es le plus malin
ici
j'ai l'impression que les gens
commencent à se dévoiler
vraiment qu'il y a tout de même
460000 dollars à la clé et la cagnotte
commence à se
remplir vous êtes
éliminé
[Musique]